this video is brought to you by
squarespace the tool to use to make a
website for your brand and grow your
business more on them in a bit
the year was 1968 and in the evening
america sat down to watch the smothers
brothers comedy hour on cbs a variety
show that featured comedy skits and
musical guests but this wasn't your
average variety show the smothers
brothers comedy hour broke away from the
traditional formula and quickly evolved
into a program that wasn't afraid to
push boundaries political satire the
vietnam war religion these were topics
that you simply wouldn't see on other
programs that played it safe but you
could see them here because of this the
smothers brothers comedy hour was a big
hit with the younger generations and
became known as a place that would
feature a lot of new acts representative
of the counter-culture era of the 1960s
among these acts was an up-and-coming
comic called george carlin but it wasn't
the same carlin that most of us would be
familiar with not yet at least he was
dressed in a crisp blue suit clean
shaven with his short hair neatly parted
to one side surprised to say that he had
not found his look yet but as the years
went on and george carlin became more
popular his hair started to grow longer
his clean shave and face was covered
with a nice thick beard his suits were
replaced by plain black shirts the
well-groomed wholesome and clean comic
was slowly morphing into a scruffier
raunchier and more cynical comedian and
he had some things to say and he was
going to say them regardless of who got
upset and what other people thought and
just like that george carlin became one
of the loudest voices of his generation
[Music]
george dennis patrick carlin was born on
may 12 1937 in new york city he was the
second son of patrick carlin and his
second wife mary berry his family life
wasn't a particularly happy one his
father and newspaper ad salesman liked
to get drunk and smack around those
close to him his first wife even died of
a heart attack after receiving one such
beating as far as george's own mother
was concerned he claimed that patrick
only hit her once afterward mary's four
brothers had him down and told him what
would happen if he ever did it again so
he stopped therefore by the time george
was born the physical abuse had stopped
but his parents marriage still consisted
of long separations interspersed with
brief reconciliations that same year the
separation became final which made
patrick carlin complete his downward
spiral into alcoholism he lost his
family and his job but he did enjoy a
brief redemption arc before his curtain
call around 1941 patrick carlin got
sober lost a lot of weight and found a
new job in radio he moved to the bronx
where he lived with his daughter from
his first marriage mary until his
unsurprising death from a heart attack
in 1945. during this time little george
grew up in the morningside heights
neighborhood of manhattan where he lived
with his brother and his mother who
worked as an executive secretary he
learned to make do by himself his mother
had to work long hours to earn enough
money while his brother who was six
years older than him often went out and
left george alone but this didn't bother
him too much he would make a simple meal
for himself and then get lost in the
world of comedy whether it was through
comics radio or later on television mad
magazine ballahu jack benny milton burl
and jackie gleason they were the ones
who raised young george during his many
hours of solitude from a very young age
george carlin discovered that he was
meant to be a performer even as a
toddler he would entertain his mother
and her friends at the office with new
dances or impersonations of famous
actors this garnered him the forays that
he coveted approval attention applause
approbation he didn't get the same
treatment in other aspects of his life
carlin grew up in a decidedly catholic
environment catholic church catholic
schools catholic camp and yet carlin
realized early on that the catholic
stuff wasn't for him that being said
george didn't mind his environment later
on he credited the progressive nuns at
corpus christi school for helping to
shape his curious and skeptical mind by
encouraging their young students to ask
questions about any and all topics in
school george quickly adopted the role
of class clown he received both
competition and mentorship from another
student dubbed john pigman a natural
performer that carlin claimed to idolize
pigman could burp on cue for 45 seconds
hence his name but his greatest act that
carlin witnessed involved pigman walking
up to two old ladies unzipping his fly
pulling out a hot dog wiener and then
cutting it in half with a pocket knife
before running away while his audience
gasped and screamed unfortunately for
george as he got older the pranks and
gags were also accompanied by bouts of
genuine delinquency in the seventh grade
he got caught stealing money from a
locker and while for a while it looked
like he might not be allowed to graduate
middle school ultimately he struck a
deal with the nuns and carlin graduated
in exchange for writing the year-end
play which was titled how do you spend
your leisure time in high school george
became a trumpeter not because he had
any particular affinity with the
instrument but because it was the only
one they had in the house after his
older brother stole it during a st
patrick's day parade other than that
high school was mostly a string of
absences and detentions george didn't
find the same relaxed and encouraged
learning environment as before so as
soon as he turned 16 he dropped out
carlin enrolled in the air force hoping
to finish his service early and then use
the gi bill to train for a career in
radio when he was 17 he was sent to
barksdale air force base in bozia city
louisiana where he worked as a radar
technician to fill his time george
auditioned for a production of golden
boy in shreveport where he met a guy
named joe monroe who was part of a radio
station called kjoe he allowed carlin to
come in for an audition and later he
hired him for weekend duty as a promo
reader and substitute dj to nobody's
surprise carlin wasn't made for military
life he got in trouble several times for
getting high or drunk on duty and for
various other offenses he wasn't big on
authority figures either in carlin's own
words when his tech sergeant chastised
him for not obeying military protocol i
told him to go [ __ ] himself to be honest
i don't think my salute was up to
standards either shockingly despite his
behavior and despite being
court-martialed three times carlin still
received a general discharge in 1957.
his role at kjoe had increased but now
that he was out of the air force carlin
had no desire to stay in louisiana he
wanted to be closer to new york so he
found a new gig with weze in boston the
job lasted a whopping three months
before carlin got canned for taking the
wez news van out and driving to new york
to score some weed however something
notable did happen during his short time
in boston he met jack burns his future
comedy partner after weze both carlin
and burns were hired by another station
called kxol in fort worth texas since
both men had comedic aspirations they
started working on a double act routine
in 1960 they relocated once more this
time to hollywood where they served as
morning djs for k-day radio again this
was short-lived because a few months
later they dropped their radio gigs all
together to focus exclusively on comedy
now let me interrupt this video very
quickly to tell you about our long time
friends and sponsor over at squarespace
now you've heard me talk about
squarespace before and look honestly if
you're making a website anywhere other
than squarespace in 2022 i would have to
ask you what on earth are you doing
because squarespace have all of the
tools you could ever need in one easy to
use place if you need a website or you
do head on over to squarespace and from
there the next step is to browse through
their extensive selection of templates
and they make this very easy they ask
you questions like what is your website
all about and you click an option like
photography for me as i've said before
i'm pursuing my dreams of becoming a
professional tiger photographer and then
they ask you your goals and there's lots
of options from collect donations to you
know with the tiger photography example
sell your services of being a tiger
photographer i'm taking this example too
far and then they show you the best
matching templates you pick one that you
love take your time there's loads of
good options and then you adjust it to
meet your needs in their ultra simple
editor you add some pictures change the
text add pages a portfolio whatever it's
all good and there's loads of other
features you can use for example pop a
little email collection form in there
and then email people who've expressed
interest being like hey you're still
interested let's do some business
together easy plus all the basics like
analytics and blogs go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com biographics to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain and now back to today's video
[Music]
burns and carlin found some success
playing at nightclubs in hollywood they
appeared on the tonight show which was
hosted by jack parr at the time they
even recorded their one-on-one comedy
album during that year titled burns and
carlin at the playboy club tonight even
though it wasn't released until 1963.
the act split up after two years because
both men wanted to go solo but they
remained close friends on a personal
level george carlin met his first wife
around that time brendon hosbrook the
two married in 1961 and stayed married
until her death in 1997 and they had one
daughter together named kelly with the
new family life on the road became more
difficult for carlin so he decided to
settle down in new york again and focus
on the comedy scene there in fact he
went back to his old neighborhood in
morningside heights and found an
apartment in the same building where he
grew up his budding solo career was
aided by a few industry veterans who saw
the potential in carlin one of them was
lenny bruce whom carlin described as one
of the few friends he had in comedy
business in fact carlin was in the
audience in december 1962 when bruce was
performing at the gate of horn in
chicago and got raided by the police for
obscenity carlin refused to show his id
and got arrested and tossed in the
paddywagon right next to lenny bruce
another comedian who lent a helping hand
was mort sal the satirist jack parr was
out at the tonight show and johnny
carson was about to come in once his old
contract expired but until then sal was
temporarily filling in he convinced the
nbc execs to bring in some new comedians
with anti-establishment material and
george carlin was one of them his first
solo appearance on the tonight show saw
him doing an impression of jfk and it
was a big hit with the audience the
television gig started rolling in pretty
steadily after that the merv griffin
show mike douglas jimmy dean the craft
summit musical and of course the tonight
show with johnny carson where carlin
appeared over 130 times during his
career all in all carlin made almost 60
television appearances in 1965 and 1966
and the following year he recorded his
first solo comedy album takeoffs and
put-ons colin would continue recording
comedy albums until his death releasing
another 17 albums during his lifetime
and another one posthumously his
numerous tv appearances continued into
the late 1960s but by 1970 carlin
thought his act was growing stale he
felt like his routines were becoming too
safe and bland due to the massive
influence of the television on his
career by now he wasn't a rookie trying
to break into the industry anymore he
had established himself and he thought
it was time for the world to see the
real george carlin
by 1970 the counterculture lifestyle was
firmly embedded into the american psyche
and although george carlin considered
himself a part of it his stage persona
certainly wasn't there was a single
event that persuaded him to morph into
the comedian that we all know and love
carlin described it as a long epiphany
one moment happened in 1969 when he was
fired from frontier hotel in las vegas
after his first show of what was
supposed to be a two-year deal for
saying the word ass during his routine
another moment occurred when carlin had
to check into the hospital for a hernia
operation and he stopped shaving during
that time and decided that he liked the
beard and then of course it was all the
acid carlin took lsd for the first time
in october 1969 at a jazz club in
chicago called mr kelly's he called it a
seminal experience that turned him into
a radically different utterly changed
reimprinted reprogrammed person from
then on the carlin you saw on stage was
more in line with the real carlin long
hair beard wearing jeans and a t-shirt
and speaking a lot of ideas that went
against the man not everyone was
thrilled with this new and improved
karlin most television shows had an
expectation for their comedians to be
clean cut and well-dressed nightclub
promoters also weren't fans of his new
edgy material carlin lost a lot of gigs
because some places simply didn't want
to stir the pot by featuring counter
culture figures his anti-vietnam war
material in particular garnered him
plenty of vehicles and even the
occasional threat from veterans in the
audience but not everyone was opposed to
the change some show hosts such as steve
allen virginia graham david frost and
hugh hefner had no problem with this new
persona and slowly but surely the
audience was also getting used to the
new george carlin because the tv and
nightclub appearance has dwindled a bit
carlin took the time to focus on his
comedy albums he released his second
solo effort in 1972 and it was popular
enough that it won the grammy award for
best comedy album which was the first of
five wins for carlin titled fm am it
featured his classic clean act on the am
side while the fm side had raunchy
counterculture material thus marking
carlin's metamorphosis from
straight-laced to hippie but it would be
his next album released later that same
year that would turn karlin into a
controversial freedom of speech crusader
titled class clown the album ended with
one of the most famous and infamous bits
in comedy history seven words you can
never say on television the words that
according to karlin affect your soul
curve your spine and keep the country
from winning the war and i know you're
thinking what are these seven words
simon well let's not repeat them here
for the sake of by monetization later
that same year carlin was arrested for
performing the routine on stage at
summerfest in milwaukee just like his
mentor lenny bruce before him but this
did not deter him if anything he doubled
down on it and carlin recorded a sequel
routine titled filthy words on his next
album occupation fool even though seven
words became karlin's most well-known
bit it was actually the follow-up filthy
words that got the supreme court
involved the saga began on the 30th of
october 1973 when new york city radio
wbai decided to play carlin's filthy
words routine uncensored about a month
later a man named john douglas wrote a
letter to the federal communications
commission or fcc complaining that his
young son heard the broadcast he also
got a non-profit media watchdog called
morality and media involved and the
whole thing turned into a back and forth
argument between the fcc and wbai's
owner pacifica over the extent of the
authority that the fcc could exert on
radio stations the whole ordeal lasted
almost five years until the supreme
court made a landmark ruling in favor of
the fcc in the case of federal
communications commission and pacifica
foundation reinforcing the idea that the
government was allowed to regulate
indecent speech over the broadcast
medium
[Music]
the controversy brought on by the court
case had no negative impact on carlin's
career who became one of the biggest
names in comedy during the 1970s in 1975
george carlin served as host for the
very first episode of saturday night
live but it didn't really leave an
impression on him since carlin was in
the midst of an intense week-long drug
binge at the time and his memory was a
little hazy there was however a
different medium that had a major impact
on his career hbo the premium television
network wouldn't really explode in
popularity until the 1980s but it still
had a dedicated audience and it offered
something that nobody else did
uncensored comedy specials the same show
that you would see in a club with all
the naughty language and obscene ideas
in its entire length just as the
comedian envisioned it delivered right
into your living room carlin's first hbo
special was released in 1977 simply
titled george carlin at usc it would be
followed by 13 more specials which for
many people became the preferred way to
enjoy carlin's new comedy routines over
the traditional albums after his second
hbo special aired in 1978 garland slowed
down for a few years when it came to
on-stage performances although this
looked like a puzzling career move at
the time since he was at the apex of his
popularity he later revealed that this
was because it suffered a heart attack
marking the beginning of his heart
issues that would follow him for the
next 30 years until his death the 1980s
were a bit leaner for george especially
the first half his health problems
worsened first he was in a car crash in
1981 and the following year he had a
second heart attack more serious than
the first while attending a baseball
game at dodger stadium carlin was rushed
to the hospital by limo and he became
one of the first people in the world to
be the recipient of a new surgical
technique using balloon angioplasty to
open obstructed arteries since the
comedy clubs weren't as packed as they
used to be carlin thought it was the
right time to renew his acting
aspirations he'd always wanted to act
his first role came back in 1968 in a
romantic comedy titled with six you get
egg roll and then in 1976 he had another
role in the hit comedy car wash but it
wasn't until the late 80s early 90s that
carlin received some genuine recognition
for his acting he had major supporting
roles in outrageous fortunes starring
bette midler and shelly long and
the prince of tides with nick nolte and
barbara streisand but it was his role as
rufus in the bill and ted bear of sci-fi
comedies that introduced george carl
into a new generation of comedy
enthusiasts in television colin had a
few small roles and produced a pilot for
hbo they never got picked up but his
longest and the most surprising
memorable role was that of mr conductor
on the kids show shining time station
based on the british show thomas the
tank engine it wasn't a role you
expected from carlin but that may be
exactly why you wanted it and he played
it for five years
the 1990s and 2000s were more of the
same for george khalid multiple hbo
comedy specials interspersed with the
occasional movie or television role he
had his own show for a while the george
carlin show created by him and the
simpsons co-developer sam simon it ran
for 27 episodes but other than that
carlin didn't really take on any other
time-consuming projects other than
stand-up comedy he couldn't afford them
carling got into trouble with the irs
for unpaid taxes and took him a long
time to dig his way out of that hole
basically he had to do what was most
profitable which in his case meant
touring the country and doing comedy
gigs he didn't have the luxury of
wasting time on an acting career that
would have probably gone nowhere but in
the end carlin credited his financial
troubles with making him a way better
comedian during this time carlin also
tried his hand at being an author he'd
already published his first book in the
early 1980s but that was mostly a
collection of jokes and stand-up
routines in 1997 carlin published what
he deemed his first real book brain
droppings it became a new york times
best seller and was followed by two more
books in the early 2000s plus a
posthumous autobiography in 2004 carlin
checked into rehab for the first time in
his life ending a 54-year high that
started when he smoked his first joint
at the age of 13. he had already given
up most drugs but was still on the wine
and vicodin diet and he needed some help
to kick this last habit once he
completed rehab he stayed sober for the
remainder of his life in 2005 carlin
accepted a new las vegas contract at the
stardust it wasn't carlin's first vegas
engagement and these gigs always placed
him in a quandary on one hand colin
absolutely hated las vegas which he
called the most dispiriting
soul-saddening city on earth in fact he
had just been fired from his previous
vegas contract at the mgm in 2004 right
before checking into rehab because he
kept insulting his audience for being
stupid enough to come to vegas on the
other hand carlin admitted that it was a
great place for a comedian to work on
new material fresh audiences came to him
every night and he didn't have to travel
the money was also good and a lot of
people in attendance weren't his fans
they just received comp tickets so they
weren't going to laugh just to humor him
carlin worked on his last two hbo
specials here with the final one it's
bad for you coming out just a few months
before his death on june 18 2008 cullen
was awarded the mark twain prize for
american humor by the kennedy center in
a statement carlin responded thank you
mr twain have your people call my people
five days later he died of heart failure
age 71. he'd just performed a show a
week earlier and he had already begun
work on his next hbo special and was
also writing a one-man broadway show
called watch my language when george
carlin was asked in interviews why he
kept working so hard in his old age he
liked to quote master cellist pablo
casales who said well i'm beginning to
notice some improvement